dear diary is sort of a funny story a
few months ago I met jack so it lasted
six hours a puppet show that auntie
bridge went to do not I don't know about
it know how much you need to make he has
a pretty nice sized puppet and then the
next week give her a little kiss you
know on the forehead there
what's talking about the baby mark my ex
and I had similar relations Daffy but I
can't go back and keep making same sex
I'm pregnant
when I can make new ones so you have no
idea which of us is the father surely
one of those days more likely they're
both equally likely so do bring along
the father if you can work out which one
he is for better or worse fate has
brought us together both of you stop it
where your nice teeth thank you
I brought you a super juice let me carry
that for you can I carry your fern
Bridget who do you want to be the father
it's like the final of the x-factor da 0
1 if you wanted to remark at 0-2 she
wants to eat yeah I have been in the
past than me how do you orchestrate such
cliffhangers in your life this is not I
thought this beef but however we choose
to do this the most important thing is
that baby
good job Bridget Gary mints 602 Mentos
which of you is the father right and who
do we have here I'm Bridget's and this
is Jack and this is Mark lovely you're
our second same-sex couple today